The Joe Rogan Experience yeah boxing you
guys it's corrupt so he's about 16-0 and
the guy could box man I seen him put
work on UFC fighters like I've seen him
Spar like Bellator Champions the guy
does work so we did like a no time limit
40 minute box and just whoever quits oh
Jesus Christ yeah just because we're
just bored in the CTE special oh [__]
yeah dude so it's kind of funny he was
actually going through some like
personal [__] and he beat me he beat me
that day like I was hating him I was
like dude you just like there's
something like there's something with
you right now after we get done boxing
for like 40 45 minutes he starts telling
me his personal issues I'm like oh [__]
yeah I did you're ready to die today
like that makes sense I feel I'm about
to go for a hike with my girlfriend bro
contemplating [__] life here yeah
yeah you win dude you [__] win that's
like when Buster Douglas fought Tyson
you know Buster Douglas's mom died and
Buster Douglas had always been like that
really talented guy with a wicked jab
who just didn't apply himself like many
really talented guys and then for that
camp he just went [__] full in yes
some guys some guys do them when they
have that like
I mean [__] even walking even sometimes
me when I walk out like I gotta tell
myself like dude you are a [__] loser
like like you are [__] you don't
belong here like just go on there and
kill this [__] you know like I
always joked I always had like I had a
teacher tell me in like seventh eighth
grade one of the one of the few years I
went to school
she I think it was like her name was
like Miss watched it I don't know
history or some [__] she looked at me
she said Sean
you're the reason you're the reason why
they build prisons oh Jesus Christ
you're a little kid imagine that naughty
but she she [__] nail on the [__]
head dude like I was a [__] [__] bag
you know right but [__] bags can grow up
and become actual men it's totally
possible to dismiss a kid at that early
in age no dude but life is strange man
like like they do very good at isolating
shitty people so I mean I mean like when
I was in elementary school I was
homeschooled in like third fourth grade
until until like you know seventh grade
I went back to school
and then they spotted me right at the
back like oh this guy's a problem he's a
[__] bag like and they'll say they
isolate you they put you in like a
school where they start two hours later
and you and an hour early because they
actually they gotta isolate you high
school the same [__] went to a
continuation school so Society like they
do well at saying hey this kid is going
to be a problem we just gotta like he's
like cancer we just can't let him infect
other people let's [__] put them away
and then you go and then you get older
and you just go to jail but it's funny
that those kids a lot of those kids they
can do things they just need a Direction
they need something and martial arts is
the best thing for those kids every one
of when people say what's the best thing
about bullies or best thing rather to
deal with bullies I might teach them how
to fight yeah you teach bullies how to
fight they're not going to want to be
beating people up they're if you teach
them how to train with real people
they're not going to be doing that man I
always say like MMA like even like
Soldiers with PTSD that's like you know
I mean I have a little bit growing up
like just not even know what the [__] be
I always thought like it sounds [__]
up but I've always like
when you hear like soldiers talking
about PTSD I'm like you [__] [__]
like this is how I was when I was a kid
right like well you know what 20 years
old like you know I I can't go in public
or I can't sleep at night I have like
I'm like what the [__] wrong with you
[__] [__] like give me a gun I'll
[__] shoot some of the [__] head
right now I don't give a [__] but then I
realized that like me I grew up so
[__] up that
that was my way of life but I couldn't
imagine being a normal [__] just
for being a normal guy trying to [__]
the high school prom queen going to
parties and all of a sudden you turn 24
and then like the veils lifted and
you're like who the [__] am I so like
once I kind of realized that I had a lot
more respect for him but you know what I
was going with that is like training man
if you guys if you guys have some [__]
up issues some demons man like train and
a lot of people that train are [__] up
so it's like you have this good like
brothership designed yes